they're three francs away now voters
grow as they will move the bum in and
it'll be v Erin and exists to come
charging in it's all forest he gets the
first he doesn't get us
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
food is pro the name itself conjures up
images of clutch plays aces back worthy
shots and biceps Wow oh it's enough and
there was a time when passion biceps has
neo bialy and snacks were kings of
counter-strike but unfortunately that
time has passed with the core officially
dissolved it is the end of an era and
while that story is totally worth
telling that's not why we're here today
because here on best of guys we like to
live in the past it's a time machine of
home we bought it online oh and guys if
you still spell esports with a dash or a
capital S or something
all you really are living in the past
lucky for you the score esports has a
brand new t-shirt to set you straight
I'm gonna post a link to it in the
comment section below and you can thank
me later now let's go back to a time
when VP were on top of the
counter-strike world starting with 2014
the year the org first signed the roster
we all remember the year they won their
first major the Year the plough began
don't take that as as biased in any way
shape or form though because else you'd
be definite they have they've impressed
a lot of people with particularly our
performance over fnatic yeah definitely
their win over fnatic was not ready
expected but Pasha here getting three
huge head shots and can
for headshots finishes it off have
passion sets the crowd on fire
it is down in the end bite as there are
men to the good here virtus Pro such
put sticks is walking around
he finished up with job
you just have to wonder when was he
going to pull the trigger and when he
did it was quite magnificent first Pro
aren't building themselves into this one
LDL C's plants slowly being held a waste
by Pasha they're opening trust again
that confidence must be right beside of
the second follow so easily
this is not what he'll do see one all
right definitely not there being
questioned on every single turn an apex
feeling confident gets stopped
Pasha finding form early on here and out
three possible victims and he's gonna
find another Pasha with the triple there
is a pearlized that's a 40 L that's well
played
absolutely well playboy Pasha now he
wants it and he gets the Paschal a DS
and gents well see whether they could
take control of Finland out to test but
as his headship
reminds us all what this VP cider
capable of follows it up with two more
lovely play from Desmond just shooting
through them blindly can can be can be
good if you know the angle but snacks
here oh he's out on the open if he has
to give and nothing but hills and look
at this one two or three four bullets
left quad kill from snacks does amazing
her spray control right there
but that open he could have got picked
off very quickly oh yeah
more people people
since this is the Eco ace can VP get
there how quick can the cavalry arrive
it doesn't know like quick enough as
pronax
[Music]
look to pick up the sick III actually
you was close - cursing there Jesus
Christ Pasha
this is a legendary mat right now for
vs. pro war struggle it has been TSM
making a huge comeback but it might have
been too late
versus pro I don't know what kind of
strength you have to find to break them
and neither lutea Sam it's gonna be
siblings left at a1 before and there is
no chance vs. pro most definitely gonna
be your champion cm I am spray through
the smoke and cynics with a good grenade
but it's too late in the day neo can you
get the last kill yes he can run Astro
they're gonna win the grand final 1614
clear shots for these thoughts he plays
here I'm coming onto the ACE tonight
the studies finding in at the moment
near hit the first dot boards in here as
it's three versus breathe trying to
fight for this fight now and the air he
hits another store the solo piece but
that is just for a moment
oh you stop that bomb is down on the
train now Fox has to go and collect that
and neo is going to try to make this
happen with this AWP he's got the smoke
there on his left that is giving it a
bit of extra space to be moving in here
with the enemy P he'll hit this shot
these guys are so on point at the moment
and passionate he'll creep through the
smoke but what can you get done here
with this PT 50 years he crawls behind
the lines finds box as creeping it's
looking to see if you can find more
players very smart stuff here from Pasha
when is he gonna pull the trigger or
will he pull out the night of precision
in position is my god
the precision incision is there the
Lannisters send their regards
overwatch but here we go it stars to
trade out take him down the Vice 4v4 now
why she's come in they lined it up time
for a second BJ's another fighting wind
[Applause]
three players on the a side renegades vs
protect against nobody holding the ankle
very spotty deep continuation spray that
is one of the most absurd things I have
seen in town strikes please somebody
explain the science behind that kind of
nonsense
Adrian for the Frank of his own and now
posh is trying to make amends for that
previous mistake with two quickfire head
shots and but if deja vu accepts much
better incumbents favor he's gonna get
his chance to essentially do a do-over
here
flashes comes through there through the
gate he's gonna pick up one kill now
it's a one-on-one he's got the triple
and he just needs one more tap here on
the space and of course it has to be
spaced together oh my god it's gonna be
bash up picking up the quad Hill what
are we witnessing now near the last one
left you know one on four Dignitas
deciding it is not over yet they wanna
fight and they want to continue to
battle neo very nearly lost the second
one will through the wall and now with
this smoke you can get the bomb planted
the problem is thickness has to have a
lot of grenades still up their disposal
they have to smokes left that has have
really be prone for neo Chris yeah so
Molotov and I bet he would love to use
the divide time but they've already
smoked out the form there's another
headshot coming through he'd have to go
over the edge touch into winning the
semi-finals here looking for another
spray Neil's gonna get a ghost
Peck's it cuts right into the grand
finals the Big Apple and snacks is
hungry he's got one kill already on the
USP low HP as well on Guardian and flame
he's trying to fake them out try to get
the middle one on long as he dances back
and forth between the box
Oh Guardian bye-bye
[Applause]
I've never seen anything like it what
the hell was that that's gotta be all
the sickest based on cards I've ever
seen therefore Phelps gets the row rank
nice shot from Taz mold down gives him
the bomb plants very important to get
thing but Phelps is a crested I'm
impressed to how aggressive he's been in
this series certainly warming up to the
fact that he's on SK and he's got a
teammate to right to the side of taco
work together but they don't go this day
Pig
[Applause]
the devil strikes the tears ties the
game
snatch holding post lifts Eagle smart
move by North just making sure that he's
not going to put that to use he's one of
those players that absolutely can hash
has taken a bit of damage early on but
there should be no chances equalize the
score always heading greater the heads
of the smoke confit doesn't know it
snacks
trying to sneak up behind him convict
not really aware what's going on yet
this could be a loss a cave very quick
and the timing here he's favoring snacks
and is he really going to go ahead a
knife
through a cheat
it is not looking good let's try to see
if they can get down but they're
standing on some of the firing getting
shot for the smoke and the alley hit of
what the balls with asphalt waiting
Cajon goes down
hometown for snacks by the way so more
than anything can want to make this work
with steals cooking it over from home
service feels afraid these senators
running away with this game looking very
good indeed
pastor though full of us is one on the
CV can do anything with this runs down
the connector there's the first kill
something to build a pop up not
believing just yet up against the devil
offset alright now we're gonna chance
those biceps big enough to push the quad
because it's store than they need to get
to a gas station they desperately need
around back through vent potentially
doesn't ought to chanted movement gets
slowed as the site to work with Lucas
people just barely goes under the cross
and what a shot for pastor 6hp
Flint's as open as he possibly there in
the site fans
and he's going to be audacious he's
gonna walk way back through vents Manny
just came from there this wasn't one
versus for the play of Pasha's life it's
planets so open hen he's gonna have no
idea smoke goes on to it he's not
picking it yet passion he's patients and
he spotted he knows he's done
got wheels on it still no gas
[Applause]
this entire career that is brilliant
the Gator coming out on snacks - who
wants to make some money how about this
group though this kind of bio they're
ready oh yeah everything's done so if
you just don't be who not today four
five all headshots what so he asked
actually planting the bomb now he can
take position this just got very scary
this browsing guaranteed orbit
guaranteed for Ni PE but snatchy
he's got an AWP playing this off the
plant they have no idea where he's gonna
be coming from it's gonna be so hard to
trade he has six HP though they do have
an incendiary there's one towards four
clip but that's not on statue will we
spots her leg can't quite find it across
he goes now they know exactly where he
is they're signs of charge him down so
that she has to be very clutch all gets
the shot in the air one more to go and
snatch see that's fantastic
how has he done that if BP can win this
rather fine 1410 they could be in a very
good place to close this one out me who
looking for the pebbles running down
don't
stickering Chris J he continues that
webpage jitter on the outside bomb site
snatches he's on one thing it's gonna be
a great rating all the way around the
back is too short oh my god if they
don't suspect this it's a good angle
could be another one snatchy patient
another kill just picking them off like
an assassin moving back into the shadows
and they have no idea what's going on
another one purse snatcher surely not
two players left in helmets just one
these PT fifties running rampant on the
ni PT side this is a massive problem and
my cause snatchy is a ninja perhaps more
so than the swedes James well guys that
was the best of virtus Pro in a nutshell
from the golden years right up to the
present and if you want to see the
Polish plow on top of the csgo world
again well I'm gonna need you to one tap
that subscribe button made the comment
section and spray the like button and
I'll see you next time thanks for
watching if you want more great content
just like this be sure to hit the
subscribe button
[Music]